[Musique]
à venir découvrir le moment mais son
père en a décidé autrement
je ne veux pas devenir tailleur je veux
partir à l'aventuré explorer le monde a
mis le vin est bon ce n'est pas un
endroit des plus agréables je t'assure
mais un jour tout va changer
un tapis volant
regardez pas pissarides j'y suis arrivé
à fait mon garçon
jetons tapis
[Musique]
tapie insultant a réussi à mettre la
main sur un tapis volant
je peux pas rentrer chez moi son tapis
il suffit d'entrer discrètement dans le
palais de le récupérer
bien sûr rien de plus at il dit à nous
c'est à piston d en faire quelque chose
en échange
j'ai l'intention par exemple de donner
ta petite amie à mes crocodiles
ding dong il ya quelqu'un là dedans